so congratulations you just wrote a
program awesome but it would never end
there in reality when writing software
is very common for requirements to
change in fact it's usually the case
requirements can change because you've
got an idea while you are writing the
application they can change because you
have a fickle manager they can also
change because the needs of your target
audience have changed since you started
work on the project originally now this
course is ultimately about teaching you
to write extensible and well-organized
code largely so you can react to those
changes in the project requirements
let's talk to a few other experts in
software development and see how often
requirements change for that
requirements change for every single
project in fact almost every single
meeting for a project leads to a
requirements change requirements can
change at any time they can change weeks
before the project or they can change
the night before it launches oh we
change requirements on the engineers all
the time well at university engineers
are actually responsible for defining
their own requirements but regardless of
whoever is defining the requirements
they keep changing all the time because
the product keeps evolving and the
requirements change because we keep on
discovering new ways of improving the
user experience and that leads to often
changing specs and requirements for the
product